il n'est plus président de la république
mais il est semble-t-il président
d'honneur à vie au salon de
l'agriculture jacques chirac était très
attendu aujourd'hui à la porte de
versailles
et vous allez voir qu'au contact des
animaux et des agriculteurs la bête
politique n'a pas perdu ses habitudes
reportage et landing samuel humaine
attendu comme la superstar du salon de
l'agriculture
jacques chirac est ici en terrain connu
et annie toujours le même salut jovial
toujours le même appétit toujours la
même envie d'aller au contact de tous
les produits du terroir sont à son goût
sont les meilleurs du monde
bhl un stand à l'autre jacques chirac on
ne boude pas son plaisir
on me demande même pas ce que je vois on
m'a même tout de suite une bouteille de
bière passage par le stand des dom tom
un petit verre de rhum et le voleur
partie d'un des bovins on n'avait jamais
de digestion salon mais j'aime beaucoup
les produits de la ferme mois
ici il marque sa préférence pour
s'attarder lections les normes oms est
très très bien c'est juste que c'est de
l'humour
il ya toujours des proches de
l'agriculture contrairement peut-être
pour président d'aujourd'hui qui est un
peu plus mais en ville donc mais jacques
chirac ne dira mot sur son successeur
une règle qui s'est imposé depuis son
départ de l'elysée à propos du monde
agricole